guys I'm so excited I'm going to WWDC
and of course the first thing that I do
when I find out is I turn my camera on
and I make a video about it because
that's what I do and I'm so freaking
excited that I don't know who else to
share it with other than you guys
because I don't know anybody else that
would be as excited as I have about this
and I got an invite to the keynote so
you can imagine my excitement I wish I
was filming when I got the email I guess
I could do like a really poor
reenactment but that being said I had a
few thoughts what I have a watchband
will I wear always a favorite for my
Eiffel wear well will I wear subtle
we'll be taking place on June 4th at the
keynote starts around pene and they are
streaming the keynote and I know that's
not really that big of news but
sometimes a Apple is known to not stream
them so you never know what to expect
with Apple so they will be
live-streaming but I will also be there
inside of the keynotes I'll be live
tweeting and I don't know probably live
streaming but I will be posting
Instagram stories like a crazy person if
you're not following me on Twitter
Instagram make sure you guys do so and
if not subscribed to my YouTube channel
make sure you do that as well don't
forget to hit the bell because then
you'll be notified when I post a new
video now that all the shameless
self-promotion is out of the way let's
take a look and what people are talking
about some predictions some rumors what
will be here at WWDC so here's the
official WWDC invites usually sometimes
these invites will give away a little
bit of a secret or info to something
that they're going to be revealing but
looking at this I'm not sure they've got
a lot of plus and minuses a lot of
buttons a lot of switches and a lot of
toggles what does it mean let's take a
look and see what some other outlets are
predicting ninety-five Mac and Mac
rumors or why to go to iOS 12 Mac OS 10
for unveil expected because this is a
developer conference obviously they do
focus a lot on software normally after
the conference at the keynote they start
rolling out beta versions of whatever
is that they talked about so here they
are mentioning Iowa's 12 Matt West 1040
vos 12 watch OS 5 and possibly
improvements to Siri in the home pod
there are also some things that I read
about potential mini home pods I think
it was rumored that Apple had sold over
600,000 home pods which is not an
astonishing number and then I kept
getting tweets in response to one of
those articles that was written that I
bought them all which is probably not
too far from the truth I'm a huge home
pop and I love it it has pretty much
replaced most of my voice interactions
with my house
I still have Alexa I don't so basically
the voice hierarchy in my house is the
home pod and then a and actually I have
a ton of powered devices all throughout
my house evident go spot up here on my
desk I also have a light that is powered
and the echo show downstairs in my
kitchen I do really love the echo a lot
but since the release to the home pod
that's pretty much what I'm using to
control my lights to play my music and
just have conversations with Siri way
too often I am excited to see what
they're doing with TV OS because Apple
is planning on having a bunch of new
programming coming out I'm assuming in
2019 that's what some of the articles
that I've read have said so I'm sure
they probably will be mentioning some of
those shows that they're working on at
wtci so I look forward to seeing what
they're working on because if I could
get it a show on Apple TV you would be
my dream Oh Apple was teasing a smarter
Siri with a new voice to show off at
WWDC so here's the thing everyone was
posting these screenshots of Syria
saying stuff about her having a new
voice but my Syria does not say that
what can we expect at WWDC this year
2018 Worldwide Developers Conference
will be held at the McHenry Convention
Center in San Jose California from June
4th through June 8th yes they have
screenshots of Syria saying I don't want
to brag but I'm getting a lot smarter it
must be all the late night studying
doing there's another one that says
Allah Allah Syria is getting a brand new
voice oh this would be interesting maybe
Syria specifically isn't getting a new
voice maybe because like Google have
John Legend to read a voice maybe
there's gonna be a celebrity cameo Siri
voice selection who would be the cool oh
wow
wow this could be interesting I mean I
used to have the Australian Siri mail
but then I just went back to basic Siri
if there was one celebrity or anybody
that Apple could get to be Siri who
would it be leave me some comments below
I would love to hear your answers so
here's an update to the Siri new voice
responses and it looks like those from
WotC 2017 which I gotta thought because
there was one response to that mentioned
that she was getting a new home so
obviously that was referring to the home
pod when Google showed off the personal
assistant when it called to schedule a
haircut I figure I saw this but it was a
Google IO
hi hair cut for a client I'm looking for
something on May 3rd there are give me
one at what point is that in ethical to
not tell someone that you're talking to
a robot I don't know but I feel like I'm
sort of okay with it but maybe I'm not
the majority all I know is if I have a
robot making my appointments and
planning my day and scheduling my life
where do I sign up
home pod mini would be a tough pill for
beets to swallow I mean if I had to
guess I just can't really imagine them
launching a home pod mini when the first
home pod didn't do as well as expected I
feel like as soon as Siri get smarter as
soon as the latest release of airplane 2
is out when you can actually control all
of your home pods then maybe I just
don't think announcing a smaller version
of the home pod is the right way to go
but if it is a lower price point then
that could make a little bit more sense
because obviously the home pod was a
little bit more on the pricey side
especially when you're comparing it to
other things on the market so if they
did release a smaller less expensive
home pod then would you guys maybe
potentially be convinced to get it you
don't have to ask me cuz you already
know my answer here on MacRumors which
is still one of my favorite places to go
for Apple news here is an iOS wish list
that they have created I think one of
the things that they
we need to focus on in iOS 12 is make it
more stable I know I have had a lot of
issues with iOS 11 from a just crashing
or apps not working properly brand and I
am innovative program so a lot of the
builds that I have are not actually
released to the public but with that
being said I do hope that well will
become much more reliable user interface
changes dark mode split screen mode for
iPhone more customization desktop mode
volume redesign if that's interesting
what do you mean with a new less
intrusive volume interface that actually
makes sense because the volume screen
does take up pretty much the entire
screen real estate ah no more shake to
undo you guys don't want shake to undo I
do accidentally activate it sometimes as
well but I really like shakes to undo or
do I not I'm not sure I think that I
like it maybe I'm just used to it AB
improvements camera controls the camera
app asks the ratio FaceTime extra wish
lists photo improvements amusing at
overhaul messages search and archive it
really is a struggle trying to search
iMessage
anytime I'm looking for something trying
to search is usually a nightmare mal
support on iPad would be very
interesting revamped Wi-Fi and Bluetooth
do not disturb improvements biometric
locking for specific apps that's pretty
cool being able to add sort of that
second layer security to specific apps
that's something I'm into always on
display for iPhone although I do feel
like just doing a simple tap I can get
access to my phone I could see
notifications and things like that it
will say though that on some other
Android phones that I've been testing
out I have really enjoyed the always-on
display although I do kind of think it's
not 100% necessary I mean I would like
it but if it kills my battery then I
definitely don't want that Siri
improvements we definitely need that
Apple is that are you planning to
address stability and performance
concerns in this update
that's much-needed Zappa was rumoured to
working on updated I pad pro that
features an iPhone hensdale edged
display with no home button and support
for face
ID even though I don't really use my
iPad that often that just sounds really
beautiful because having this edge to
edge display just really has changed the
whole look of my phone it's basically
changed the look of phones in general so
that's
really the standard now Apple often
introduces refreshed Macs
the iMac MacBook Pro and MacBook are all
waiting 2018 refreshes my computer is
loud because I'm capturing my screen at
the same time and everything is saving
so to set this off to the side say hi to
everybody say hi say hi hi guys this is
my dog Maddy you just wanted to come say
hi you don't have to be scared you're
just on a desk here sit down
you ate it hi welcome to my unboxing
desk Maddy price is Maddy Maddy say hi
to everybody I think I think he hates it
do you want me to put you down here
I gotcha bud why do you want to decide
it's okay I got you bud okay he's
looking at me like why did you do that
so who knows what Apple actually has
planned but you guys can stay tuned here
to my youtube channel twitter instagram
because I will be posting pretty much
non-stop from the event you guys want to
leave me some comments below and let me
know what you're expecting what are you
looking forward to what is the one thing
that you most are looking forward to
then potentially announcing I will see
you guys in my next video
thanks so much for watching I'll see you
later bye I gotta go take my dog for a
walk now that I upset him by putting it
on my desk
[Music]